I heard you say something there I didn't
say anything how can we get you two back
together on screen again Time Machine
just get yourself a time machine
yeah or tune into a rerun you saw it
didn't you see it
yeah I thought Jerry Seinfeld continues
to play coy about a Seinfeld reboot but
he stepped out in support of his former
co-star Julia louis-dreyfus in
Washington DC as she received the Mark
Twain prize how special is it for you to
be here honoring your close friend
Julian so special because she she was
always I always felt like she was the
diamond she was the sparkle of the show
that really made it the right chemistry
the right formula you know without her I
really don't think the show would have
been successful I'm gonna have to take
this call Jerry what's the emergency
Jerry's back on the TV show George and I
are moving to California do you remember
her audition what do you remember from
that just her and I in the room she came
in to meet and Larry was there and we
were just talking and we had two pages
of a scene and I said let's just read
this together just the two of us sitting
there and we read it and I said that's
it she said yeah I mean literally 30
seconds into it I said yeah this is
exactly right yes she's what's your
favorite Seinfeld memory of her with her
I think it was a was it the Festivus
scene happy Festivus what are you doing
here that big table and we were all
exhausted and it was Yom Kippur and I
was fasting and we were just we were a
wreck you know we're trying to do this
scene and you're just laughing and she
had our makeup was running it's just how
he just remember if we could be a total
mess we were a total mess a lot of the
time she has been through so much New
Year yet she continues to make a slap in
the his smile what is your favorite
memory with her making you laugh and
smile Oh making me laugh just hanging
out you know we would we would you know
we would hang out on the you know the
apartment set of the show that's where
we hung out so we would sit on those
couches I would sleep on that couch
during the day I'd be sleeping there and
they'd know I never them and they'd wake
me up come on we gotta rehearse you know
that was where I live yeah I thought
what no what you say nothing